so it is my great pleasure to introduce
to you somebody
who really should not need much of an
introduction uh
ray dalio who is the founder the chief
investment officer and chairman
of bridgewater associates a mega hedge
fund a very
big player in financial markets for a
long time
um ray welcome thank you very much for
doing this
oh it's great to be here so
it's it's a pleasure for me i have to
sort of put this on the table
you know i've been a big fan of yours
for a very long time
starts back in the days dow jones
newswires as
a foreign exchange journalist and we
used to get the daily observations that
came in through the door
and i was just stunned i was found them
just such an interesting insight and
for years i've wanted to be wanting to
have a sit down with you to discuss some
of the big picture issues that we'll
discuss today and when i got involved in
bitcoin i felt like i've got to get ray
dalio thinking about these things
because i figured
uh you'd be interested in them and sure
enough daily observations from
you know a few months back landed on our
desks and you'd sort of wade it into
bitcoin and given
some very very interesting perspectives
on that and we'll get to that uh
in a little while uh but let's for now
uh start off on on a big picture
angle here you've been of late
speaking a lot about this long-term
debt cycle issue this this state of the
world and putting it in the sort of
almost
75-year context of where we are
um i'd like you to lay out the thesis
and this sort of gets back to
where we are with debt globally where we
are with the role of the dollar
in the global economy the state of
inflation and the role of central banks
in money
uh so that's the starting point for the
conversation can you just
lay out the thesis at this stage uh yeah
um
about um i don't know eight ten years
ago i began to
see things that didn't happen in my
lifetime before but happened in the
1930-45 period
and then i thought um i better
go back and study the rises and declines
of reserve currencies
and so before the dollar there was the
british pound and before that there was
the dutch gilder so i looked at these
cycles um and you see the cycles
and i see we're we're in the cycle
there's a financial component to that
cycle
which has to do with the creation of
debt
and financial assets
and then the limitations of that and
we'll get into
that in a in a moment that's then
there's
um an internal um cohesiveness
clash cycle that has to do about money
too
which has to do with as the wealth gaps
grow and
the values gaps grow and political
graphs grow you have a greater amount of
conflict and then there's a third cycle
that will all relate to each other but
the third cycle
is the rise of a great power to
challenge
an existing great power such as the rise
of china challenging the united states
and they all sort of go together because
you know it comes down to basics um are
you strong do you do you
are you strong economically and so on so
let me just fast forward on the
financial part of that
um um the cycle
is really um that uh
debt and cred credit creates
buying power and um
so it's a short-term stimulative and
it's a longer-term depressant
because you have to pay it back and so
every time
an economy gets weaker and so the they
jab it with credit and it pumps it up
and then but it accumulates this debt so
it rises
and they keep doing that until it
becomes more and more difficult so as
you get down
to something like a zero interest rate
it becomes more difficult and also the
pile
of that debt is also the pile of
somebody's assets they own the bonds
they own the financial assets and all of
those financial assets
are claims on real stuff real goods and
services so when we think about money or
storeholds of wealth
and you say where is your wealth we tend
to
define it as those financial assets but
those financial assets
have no purpose other than to sell them
to get the goods and services and when
the pile becomes
very big and the incentives for not
holding that are are no longer there
you have a problem okay because like
it's so
it's gone through history uh you have
those financial assets want to go
to get the tangible assets in the old
days that would be go get the gold
or something but when you go there
there's too many claims
for to get it and then you have that
problem and inevitably
there's the printing of money so we can
so we can think of the financial system
we'll start there before we get to the
wealth gap and the other thing
you can basically see that the cycle
that we're in
the new world order began in 1945
at the end of world war ii and that is
when the united states won the war
these cycles happen this way there's a
conflict there's a winner
and there's new rules of the game and
there's a new reserve currency
and that's the dollar and the dollar was
um
connected to gold and it wasn't really
nobody thought of it as having any
value it was like checks in a checkbook
and the
the gold the money was the gold
and so the little pieces of paper would
go get you the gold
and that system then resulted
in us spending we had the privilege of
the reserve currencies
people want to lend to us we would spend
more than we earned and those who got
these dollars
turned those dollars in to get their
gold
and the gold stocks went down and then
in 1971 i remember well because i was
clerking on the floor of the new york
stock exchange president nixon
says to the country or since to the
world in his very
polite and diplomatic way that you're
not going to get the gold anymore
and so there was the devaluation okay
meaning
okay you and the printing of money and
we had the 70s and so on
so we're in a situation that's like that
we have
the decline in
in you know the decline in real
rates the pushing of a lot of liquidity
around out because there's not
enough money not enough hard money so
they have
to uh they but everybody needs more
money
so uh we need that more money so money
is
credit you can make it up so the
government creates
a lot of credit and the central bank
prints a lot
of money and there's not much incentive
to hold this money think about cash if
you hold cash
um you get no interest rate but there's
an
inflation rate that's let's say two
percent a year and then you have
taxes and things and if you think about
bonds
okay that's not a there's not much
incentive there
and you know negative in in some places
and so now we have a supply demand
problem okay because as you look at the
budgets and you look ahead
we know we're going to need a lot more
money a lot more
debt and it's go and this is all the
cycle the
is you need the more money you have to
print that you need more money so
taxes go up and that produces the
dynamic now i can keep going on about
what happens in that dynamic
it may be capital controls you start to
go to
things where that money wants to go
someplace and it goes to
almost anything else particularly at all
that time i learned in
71 painfully learned in 71
that it caused that it causes like
stocks to go up
it causes everything we can deal with
the mechanics of the stocks gold
bitcoin um real estate uh everything to
go up
because it's really going down in
dollars and that's the part of the cycle
we're in i think i should stop there
because i want to just nail down i think
it's a critical point here and we'll go
a
little bit further beyond in a moment
but um inflation right so
so right now it seems to me that the
public debate around this
fixates on on the cpi right and it's a
as if to say until we see that thing get
up above two percent we see this concern
then then it's just a you know demand
and supply problem there is not enough
money in the world there is demand for
money
and therefore everything's okay right
but you're talking about this other
dynamic that's going on
that is very much that seems to me
symptomatic of this problem
without those those funds have to go
somewhere and
they're not going necessarily into eggs
and you know groceries
but they are going into stocks into
bitcoin into
you know fixed to real estate and and
fine art and things like that
yup how does that work and why is one
happening and not the other and
and are we talking about the wrong thing
if we're focusing on
on consumer inflation well um
yeah first of all there are two types of
inflation
there's the supply demand inflation when
demand is strong enough
and it presses up against capacity like
you don't have enough labor unemployment
rates are low
and capacity is low and then prices go
up and there's that kind of inflation
and then there's a monetary inflation
which comes from the
supply of debt
being too much so that they produce
more of the money and the holders
of those financial assets particularly
bonds
because bonds is just a promise to
receive
money that the central bank can print
the holders of that
then go into those other things
and then what happens is then you you
just have to follow the money
so you see who gets the money and then
when they get the money you see what
what they do with that money
so um let's say if you change who gets
the money now
because we're going to change that taxes
will change that
other things will change that that goes
then to those other people
so the inflation the the big inflations
are the ones that are really most
important are
not the ones of the supply and the
demand
they are the ones like that which
followed
1971 my example okay
there's not enough money you you put it
down um you'd value in other words you
sever the link and then with that
then there's a monetary inflation you go
into those other things
and then you know you have that so the
risk or let's say our there's two risks
um we will have a hell of a lot of
demand
because we put all that money in cash is
all over the place
and even investments uh you know all the
investments go up because of so much
cash and how do you find a good
investment
but but in also it there's so much money
and it'll
ch change the amount that is in the
hands of individuals and so on
and so if uh now it's in cash and
that'll move on because
cash is trash i mean i i'd say that
because it'll have that negative real
return so we're going to
um the real risk you'll you'll
experience
more inflation um
right now a lot of it is in cash and
there'll be a lot more money being
produced
and but you'll experience that more in
that kind of
inflation things will go up you could
see inflation in
houses inflation and you know many
things
is going up and then you'll start to see
probably
some labor inflation if you start to see
labor inflation and so on
it'll be a different kind of inflation
though it'll be
um like because we're in a more digital
society
um there won't be that those things can
be produced that supply of
digitalization can be produced without
the capacity constraint
but the big monetary inflation is the
thing
where do i store my wealth
okay because what happens to the markets
is then when you go to those other
things let's say you go to stocks you go
to
real estate you go to other things
because they're getting out of that
as those prices rise
like a bond their future expected
returns go
down and as they come closer
to the interest rate so now you've got
whatever the interest rates are it
depends on the country but it comes down
then there's no longer the incentive to
buy
those things and you could have trouble
and it becomes very difficult to tighten
monetary policy because the whole thing
falls apart you know everything's
interest rate sensitive and so the
central bank has got to
then print that then you have negative
real
returns in stocks and other assets
like we did in the 70s but the nominal
return goes up
that pattern has happened over and over
and that's i'm just trying to describe
the mechanics of it right so maybe look
at let's look at this from the
geopolitical
perspective you talked about the
importance of there being a challenger
to the hegemon and you know we've got
china out there
i want to sort of frame this though in
the moment
uh of a little more than a year ago when
the world really went into the first
sort of financial aspect of the covert
shock
and at that moment it was clear that
there was a
a desperate shortage of dollars you know
we you've talked about this rise up of
debt around the world and much of that
debt is dollarized
and so in particular in europe we had
this huge demand for dollars
and the feds did what it's done before
but in this time it did it on a
much larger scale and that is that it
printed a lot of money at home but also
opened those swap rates and flooded
europe
with dollars as well and it was
interesting because the illusion
i felt at that time that i was hearing
from a lot of folks was like oh my god
look how strong the dollar is the dollar
has never been stronger
because everybody wants it but it struck
me that there was something falling
apart here that the actual dependence on
the dollar
was it was a political problem now that
there was this
you know we are locked into the u.s
monetary policy cycle in a way that we
never had before and that is
really anti-democratic um and so this
sort of
it seemed to me that the cracks are
there right now when it can look as if
it's too strong at the same time as you
rightly point out china is rising and
i'll get to
what i think is the other piece of this
the technological part of it the rise of
bitcoin and the rise of central bank
digital currencies in a moment but
lay up for me what all this means on
that global stage the geopolitical piece
of this
and and then and china as well well it's
a great power to be able to print the
world's currency
but it just happens like the british
pound happened and it happens like the
dutch gilder happens
and as you point out if you have a debt
in a currency
that you don't print uh you have a short
position and so that's what you know
money and money and credit uh is not a
fixed supply it just kind of contracts
you've got a debt cred
contraction and so if you look at what
happened
in um
april 8th and 9th where the government
the central government and the central
bank got together
and did that that happened very quick
and so you hardly notice the short
squeeze
if you go to the time before that two so
that took
barely days maybe we maybe a couple of
weeks
if you go to 2008 that took
nearly a year but it was the same thing
and if you go
to uh 71 it was the devaluation and if
you go
to march 5th 1933
it was the same thing but it's pr that
took place
it was 1929 and it took until 33 and you
have a depression
so if you don't do this you have a
depression that's why
the depression lasted you know 1920 it
was 30 and
through 33 the beginning of 33 you have
the depression
and then and then 2008 was much shorter
and this one was a nanosecond and much
bigger
and so it creates that short squeeze
there is a supply
demand for these bonds now so it's
important to understand that
so um now the world because it's a
the dollar is a world's reserve currency
the dollar the world is long a lot of
dollars or dollar denominated assets or
dollar denominated debt let's say is
about 23 trillion dollars of dollar
denominated debt
that they're holding the holders of that
are holding like they can convert that
and so on and you're going and there's a
supply demand problem
because if you have a deficit that means
you have to sell sell
bonds and so that means that the
holdings
of those bar bond holders have got to
increase they they have they're
overweighted in debt
in dollar denominated debt it doesn't
pay much
i mean it's negative real returns and
you've got to buy a whole lot more
of those bonds and so and they don't
want to buy
a whole lot more of those bonds for
various reasons
and then you also have china as a more
effective
competitor for capital so yeah um
because what's happening is it's a
competitor
and it's not just a competitor and let's
say military it's a
capital markets competitors the
companies it's producing
and so on in 2015
um only two percent of chinese markets
were open
foreigners now it's over 60 percent and
if you look at the relative pricing and
so on
um it's a whole different story because
they're not
doing quantitative easing they're not
doing whatever it is they still have an
attractive bond market
they have attractive capital markets
that are more open
and as they're more open and peop big
investors
institutional investors central banks
and
view themselves as underweighted there
even if you want
balance you you want balance you're
getting the supply
demand for these us bonds coming
and you want to move that that creates a
supply demand
problem that then gets can only be
manifest in
resolution by either the u.s raising
interest rates to attract that or the
dollar devaluing
okay so now we're dealing with that
dynamic so this is very similar
um when we went from you know this 1970s
uh early 70s excuse me
late 60s to 1970 we had a recession
and then there was a difference between
what was then the deutsche
mark and the yen and how much they were
printing
and how much the united states was
printing and that was the problem
so you have a difference in monetary
policy supply demand
that is working on that so when you
bring up china
it's not just a geopolitical and not
just the technology or
you know it's a capital competitiveness
thing
that means that when you buy um a
chinese financial asset
like buying an american financial asset
you have to buy their currency
so it's supportive up to their currency
and it's also supportive to their assets
and then in addition part of this
cycle has always been that um
if you're trading if you're a large
percentage of world trade
china now is the higher highest
percentage of world trade
then there's the capacity to bill in
your your currency or lend in your
currency
china has been very reticent to do that
not to disrupt the system and so on but
you're seeing more the
internationalization of the remnb so it
has appeal
for borrowers and lenders and
and so on and so that dynamic is really
following the same arc of
uh monetary systems and empires pattern
so you know speaking of that uh somebody
else that i've spent a lot of time
following over the years because i've
always been through this big
international monetary trends
barry eichengreen i think is probably
the the greatest historian
of international monetary system and he
has pointed out
that it's not always the case that you
just flip the switch and you go from one
you know single reserve currency from
say the british pound
to the dollar but there are these
periods where it's it's a competition
there are multiple currencies that are
actually competing
and there's no reason to say that we're
going to flip and suddenly become and
it's hard in fact to imagine the chinese
suddenly becoming replacement right so
now
we are entering into this world where
perhaps there's competition
and this is where i think the technology
part of this becomes very very
interesting because
you know we're moving to digital
currencies i think that is a thesis that
is definitely worth considering in this
context
and before we even think about bitcoin
we've got china right china is producing
uh a digital currency it's coming out
with this um you know in a
pilot mode right now but we all know
where it's headed and as much as it's
focused on the retail market it is
impossible to imagine that it would not
take this into the international realm
and now you have much more fluidity and
you also have
a competition for money that's not just
based on all those aspects that you
described
of the strength of the economy but of
the money itself
because this money is now programmable
this money has a quality
that prior money does not have you can
turn things on and off with this money
my view is that the biggest advantage to
china is not that it is
you know an attractive currency per se
but and there are all sorts of reasons
why people are worrying about china's
you know
privacy controls and so forth but rather
that by inserting it into
not only its domestic economy but also
its international relations it will make
all of that more efficient the the money
itself will remove a lot of the friction
for the system
and that that's going to be a powerful
competitor to the us
so now you have china versus the us but
you also have
you know we saw facebook and it's in its
partners come up with this
libra concept uh now now called dm
it's a sort of a corporate currency but
of course you know the currency that you
know we're moving to talk about now as
well
decentralized currencies uh like bitcoin
right as an option for people in a fluid
digital economy as you described in
addition to gold of course right
so there's this view that we're entering
into this competitive environment
um what do you i mean if you do you
agree with that uh
assessment and what does it mean for
how this plays out uh for all of us
well yeah it the history of currencies
you know um you go back
uh uh just before there were always many
many currencies in private currencies
nobody even
had um a central bank
and so then uh the bank of england um
actually i think it was just before that
it may have been sweden but anyway the
bank of england says we want a monopoly
on our on currency and we will control
it
and so before then you had all these
currencies competing in
different which ways and then we come
back to this world
in which um there is your currency and a
dominant currency
um and but you're totally right
that what happens is um uh each country
would like to close the borders and
control
its currency that which is going on
because it
it's certainly one of the greatest paris
probably the greatest power
that a government has is the capability
over its currency and to control where
money and credit go
okay they would like to control those
borders
but then the question is how
what is the capacity to control those
borders
as the alternative currencies um
compete and you know it's like you know
gresham's law which is you know
the the bad uh the good money drives it
goes
outside you save it and then the bad
money stays and so there's always been
a money that is the international
currency and always the preferred
one that you'll change it was always
gold
or silver because not only because it
was tangible
but because it had an intrinsic value
um it couldn't be controlled um
in other words you got it it's like
holding diamonds or something
and you now you now you've got it it has
its intrinsic
and in periods of conflict nobody wants
it's
another currency think about the chinese
owning a trillion dollars worth of
us bonds that the united states say i'm
not going to give you any money or
whatever maybe we'll put negative
interest rates or maybe you don't get a
dime
so now oh you're you've hit it right on
the spot
okay the gov the countries will want to
control their currency and now we're
dealing with what's under control
and what's not but you're also dealing
with more
international controls on these rules
so when you uh in other words they're
going to agree
um that uh they don't want you to
run wild with your uh your currency uh
just again i'm dealing with as a
storehold of wealth as different from a
transaction because i'm talking about
you know what is it its value is
distinct from the transaction
for efficiency yeah it seems like
ethereum or others in terms of maybe
others you know more about that than i
do
in terms of transactions and certainly
for china
it has a lot of advantages including
um it can't be sanctions cannot be
it has the it clearing system it's its
own clearing system and their benefits
but all these currencies
are going to be competitive and then the
question is
how they're allowed to compete and one
of the great things i think
as a worry is the government having the
capacity
to control almost any of them including
bitcoin
or the digital currencies so i mean they
know where that
they are and they know what's going on
and so on
and then we have to have that particular
issue and so that's why i ask you i'm
interested you know like if you'll have
uh cases where you know it'll be
outlawed and it really takes
quite something um to
um you know uh say i'm going to have it
even though it's outlawed and so on
those have consequences and you're
seeing that like in india and other
places so
the question as we wrestle with this
are those how will they compete what are
the pros and cons and the thing that i
would suggest is we agree on the
environment and we agree on the dynamic
but why does it have to be one or the
other
i mean why why can't it just be like i
don't really
know how they're all going to compete
and i want a
properly diversified portfolio of gold i
mean
you know you know the bitcoin people the
bitcoin people in the gold people the
gold people
and i think that you you have to think
about okay
you do you have enough of the
diversification of those
alternative currencies yeah well i
certainly wouldn't describe yourself as
what
what we in this sector call a maxi i'm
not a bitcoin maxie uh i i don't think
it is the one and only necessarily
what i'm most interested in is this
competitive uh process
the hayekian moment right where there's
multiple currencies and
the best one win certainly for the
storeholder of wealth component of this
but the best ones
for the individuals are not the best
ones for the governments
so this brings me to a question then
this is where it does we do start to
drill down into bitcoin because
some people will take some issues with
what you said about the government's
ability to control
it i think that there is a simplistic
idea that bitcoin
cannot be controlled uh because
ultimately they do control the on the
off ramps and you're right and so when
it comes to mining at least
you know there is knowledge of where
those miners are
however uh we do see and we know that
mining can spin up anywhere very quickly
it it goes to where there is energy
basically
and on top of that you know it's hard to
imagine in my mind that they're that
they're going to
there's not going to be cohesion around
this you're talking about a competitive
environment
where governments themselves are
competing so if there is no
international accord
on how to control bitcoin it will pop up
somewhere else and so the
the idea that it cannot be shut down
entirely
is is a very appealing one especially
when you look at how
uh bitcoin has become more and more
efficient um
is that is that naive how do you see you
know i
uh um
i i i i would say um
look um if you have
you know you have private wallets to
cold storage and so on then you got to
transact
and so on on the history um
like i would say and governments
cooperating
against that or even how do you deal
with it
i don't know for sure but i would say
one would have to consider that history
would suggest that's a significant risk
if you feel
that you others are better judges of
that risk
um but you know it's um anyway you judge
um
that risk i can't i can't say i would
say
it's a real you know it certainly has to
be considered a
real risk because if you take most of
bitcoin which is owned
and how it's owned and so on it's not
owned in that way and it's going to be a
big thing
and i don't know and then you know there
are other things i don't know you know
uh what what is the the next demand and
and so look at all currencies have died
all currencies have devalued or died
there's not one you know i mean maybe
gold can
be considered gold gold might have the
gold
hasn't but i'm saying all currencies
and i've i've been to i was to palau and
i saw
paladins a little island and i saw um
they had these giant like wheels of
uh stone and so on and i'll give you an
example
and that was the currency and when they
were
they told me the story when they were
taking uh one of those
on a canoe from one island to another um
it uh it cracked and fell off and it
sunk
and they still the owner of that and the
owners
still treated that as having value
so it's a funny thing i you know what is
it's imputed value it's not intrinsic
value
okay intrinsic value is another thing
you have a house you have a car
okay that is intrinsic value as you
start to get to imputed value and so on
you're entering a different world and i
don't know the answers to
i'm not here to um give you the answers
to those questions but uh so
diversification
would be my main um
perspective like what's our strategy for
all this in a moment but let's just
drill down this just a little bit more
if it's okay because this imputed value
i think is a function of as
you know its collective belief in in
many respects right
and you know it's been interesting to
watch i've been covering bitcoin now for
uh eight years uh and
adoption certainly has grown and in this
year we've seen
um institutions like yours i mean i
don't know whether
you guys are actually brought into
bitcoin but i certainly know that you're
interested in it
we've certainly signed up for bitcoin so
we've certainly got a number of these
big institutions now buying into that
it's still obviously a you know a small
proportion
relative to gold certainly relative to
dollars certainly relative to the global
marketplace
however how important is that
institutional buy-in from a political
perspective
does it impact the policy decisions
going forward whether it's a big corner
for any asset for that matter
does the financial class have an impact
on the decisions that are going to be
made about you know these these rules
as you say are going to be really
important going forward on
you know which currencies and which
still holds of wealth get
impacted we certainly know from the 2008
crisis that they do wall street's too
big to fail
situation was the defining moment of
that event
you know do we do we look at this coming
moment
and the decisions governments make from
the perspective of who owns the assets
and their influence
their lobbying power over those
governments is that important and in the
case of bitcoin if it grows does it
become important
yeah i think bitcoin's greatest risk is
its success
because as it becomes more right now
it's not such a big deal
um and you know fighting it
is more of a big deal um and
that's that's it because it's not that
big a deal
um as it becomes a bigger deal
and more of a threat let's say people
want to sell their bonds
and they want to buy bitcoin
um and they want to do that in a bigger
way
like buying gold or something in a
bigger way
um and then there's more transaction
they lose control over that
and that's an existential risk
so yes that's connected and the more
we create savings in it
the more um you might say
i'd rather have bitcoin than the bond
personally i'd rather have bitcoin than
a bond um
and um and then the more that happens
um then it goes into bitcoin and it
doesn't go into credit
and then they lose control of it so yeah
that's a risk
yeah so so maybe there's a tipping point
right where
uh it's at the moment it's not something
they they worry about
uh you know because it's too small it
then gets
greater demand it gets more adoption it
becomes a threat
i suppose there's a point at which
governments might get worried that it
then passes to a point where they cannot
control it anymore because it is so
broadly
already held and the influence of those
asset holders is too strong so
at some point watch the watch the total
um total value of bitcoin right now is
a little over a trillion dollars total
value of uh
bonds uh is about 20 20 uh our bonds is
a
u.s dollar bonds about 23 trillion
dollars and so on
not only watch the price although in
bitcoin's case the demand profiles the
price
watch the total values of those things
and as those and you know plotted on a
chart and watch
those things and watch the flows because
if you start to see
that kind of thing you could almost see
you know like the blow off and you know
and then
and then that kind of reversal right so
just to put it in perspective some other
numbers like there's a trillion
little over trillion dollars in bitcoin
if for gold
um if you take out central bank
ownerships because central banks won't
own bitcoin as a i don't believe for
various reasons that i can
digress it as an asset and if you take
out jewelry
from gold uh from then you have
a bit over five trillion dollars so if
you were to look at it now
and you were to say a port what's what's
a person who wants
a diversification of those two things
it's about
you know like 80 20 right now in the
world
so that's something i'd watch too but i
think those things
probably are going to rise relative to
the bonds
and it would transpire that way so you
want to watch those numbers
and uh and see how those go the other
thing i think that it's worth watching
and this is something you know
i don't know how much you've looked at
it but i would humbly
uh suggest you do uh is to look at the
overwhelming amount of kind of um
wild west uh unhinged
uh relentless innovation that
is happening around the crypto space in
many respects to create
as as close as they can get to it a
truly decentralized model that allows
them to get around a lot of these
constraints it's not necessarily
looking for something illegal but it's
to build a structure
that is not dependent on you know any of
these controlling forces
be they you know a bank or a government
right and so the d5 world the
decentralized finance world
it can be looked upon as this furious
effort to build this and so i i just
think that's a very important thing
perhaps you can keep being informed of
that that sounds
that sounds very important yes so with
that in mind
um you just you start talking about
diversification and and everything else
what you know what are your
recommendations what does a person i'm
also interested in this
you started off talking about zero
interest rates and sort of being the
return on financial assets being driven
down essentially close to zero
and i'm thinking you know i'm a little
older you and i probably you know
it's not as big an issue for us but i've
got young daughters who are just
leaving school for whom the future
of zero interest rates you know on what
they're going to be earning over the
years is just
highly unattractive and has all sorts of
problems along the lines what you're
just talking about
you know what do what does a smart
portfolio look like
with that in mind but also obviously the
bigger
you know international hegemonic uh
issues that you were talking about well
um
like i you know i think the same thing
um
these things come across about
once in a lifetime or um
and the problem with most people
is if they didn't experience it they
don't understand it
um i i i think there's it creates this
environment i would recommend to anybody
who's interested i put it on linkedin
my study of what's called the changing
world order
and it goes back and it shows the
patterns of there
because it's like um if you were in the
20s
you're experiencing the 1920s
and so on and you cannot imagine what's
ahead
because it hadn't happened in your
lifetime the new world order
so we're in a spot of the cycle
it's not just about interest rates it's
about
uh the whole enchilada you know um
and that could be financial like
which has to do with um taxes and then
trying to escape taxes and then trying
to control
and all of that dynamic and then it has
to do with
conflicts between the left and the right
and the capitalists and the socialists
and how
they can be with each other that affects
the environment
and then it has to do with the changing
world order
in terms of china and the united states
and so on
so your children will really
you know in order to understand what's
likely to happen
over the next one two three four five
years
you really need to go back and study
about what happened in the 1930-45
period and so on so forth
and and so i'm not going to be able to
summarize that here but i did
put that that description out there for
those who are interested because you've
got to be
prepared for all of those possibilities
it's rather grim unfortunately because
those years weren't the weren't the with
the brightest ones in
in human history like i we we don't
realize how
unbelievably lucky we were i was born in
49
so five four years after the the
united states had 80 percent of the
world's money because gold was the
world's money
they had control of the world central uh
the power because they had nuclear
weapons and they were dominant
and there was this wind and that always
happens there's the cycle
and that always happens and then you
experience it but if you go back to
1900 just a little bit earlier
and you look at um what you would see
that almost all wealth just pick a
country
and say i have a store of wealth and
was is it stocks bonds the currency okay
it's destroyed in those years
with not just um
not just the
currency thing but a combination of
taxes
and then conflicts over wealth and power
and so many things
so think about if you're instead of an
american
you're a german or a japanese
you got wiped out totally you happen to
be
lucky if you were an american but
if you let's say if you're a brit um
it's it you you had some money but it
got taken away most of it got devalued
or taken away
and so you've got to know those stories
yeah if anybody's watching the crown uh
so it's been the ongoing story of many
many respects of
the current monarch's life is dealing
with the fallout from all of that for a
very long time right
um you know i i i spent six years of my
life in argentina and i often say oh
look imagine you're an argentine because
there this this this this boom bust and
the destruction of your wealth
aspect is a visceral element of you know
that a much shorter cycle a 10-year
cycle is what sometimes sometimes people
describe there so
clearly something very real and so
when you start to think of all the way
take your wealth
and you start to think how do i protect
that from
all of those things okay
let's see what those inventions are
if you can find the answer really to
those inventions
there'll be a hell of a lot of demand
for that you'll have the governments
against you
but you but you know that'll be what
it's like
well on that on that note you know one
of the pieces that you
always refer to and every good economist
any good analysis of history will
uh to see where things are going is is
productivity and
and innovation as an element of the
growth story ultimately the
driver of long-term growth presumably is
is that
is is productivity how we grow and you
know it's
my view is that that we we have we don't
necessarily measure it appropriately
like i
i think there's this this this is that
we've we don't have productivity now
uh you know ultimately um you know we
may well have all this
great social ephemeral interconnectivity
but the things that we the cars we drive
or the bridges we cross or whatever
are still the sort of things that we've
had from from many years ago without you
know this
electronic connections to them but
they're ultimately the same thing
um but i think there's another way of
looking at things and and that is that
we are moving into a face phase where
innovation is less about the mechanics
of things
and about the dynamics of social
innovation
that that we've created frameworks
whereby
the power of of collective action uh the
power of forming economies
is something that is now in itself this
innovative process and if you look at
at china um i think that the one of the
things that's really interesting about
the people often look at china and they
say
you know in the past china's never gonna
be able to beat the united states
because they're an imitator which in
itself was
you know a very sort of i think almost
racist and simplistic way of thinking
about
things but also completely missing what
i think is the most dynamic aspect of
china's innovation
that it is not about whether or not it
is making the best cars or the best
solar panels
but that it is figured out through
things like digital money
and these really interesting social
networks how to form
new economic structures uh you know and
they work in the overseas chinese
and there is this phenomenal chinese
social commerce innovation um and i
think that that it's possible to look at
the rest of us and see something
happening similarly
um you know whatever you make of the
crazy gamestop
uh uh episode um you know
not to say it was necessarily a good bet
and ultimately the crowd
lost in that case the idea that you have
these tools that allow people to
collectively organize
i think is very very interesting and
that is really at the heart of what i
think is the most interesting aspect
of the crypto space that it is these are
communities
who are given not only the tools to
collectively build open source
innovation
but they're incentivized to do so
because the tokens and the assets
they're creating
brings in this thing so you build this
flywheel of innovation
so i'm wondering you know with that in
mind i mean
do we are we doomed uh to sort of
this kind of failure of productivity to
keep up with the massive
debt overhang that you described because
ultimately that is the best way out
rather than printing money obviously
or or is it possible that we could you
know be be just
moving into a different environment of
of innovation that might actually be
a way out in a constructive sense
um rather than the doomsday scenario
yeah
uh uh um there's
there's there's a real economy
and there's a financial economy and we
shouldn't confuse those things um
[Music]
in other words people think okay the
price of the stock the price of the
house
the prices go up and they think they're
richer and that's not true
it's the same house they just do the
accounting for it and then
oh they say i'm richer they're not
richer they have the same house
and so um i i want to separate the
financial that we're talking about with
productivity which is the real thing
and i agree with you that um they don't
know how to
um you can't actually
uh calculate it efficiently because
they um you're trying to measure one
thing against
another using a common denominator and
so
let's let's say for example um
if you would imag if pictures
were gdp if all gdp were pictures
and then you would say if what's the
value of pictures
and you would say it plunged to zero but
yet there are more pictures
you could take them on your phone and
you could take them all around
and there's not a good translation
mechanism
for saying okay actually we got all of
this other stuff
around and it's and it's so because you
haven't not a common denominator when
you try to put
that in value if you change value so it
can't be well
productivity can't be well measured but
at the same time
we know that we're changing
um and uh intellectually
and so on we're are accelerating that
the human
um you know it used to be the muscles
and then it sort of goes
higher and higher and and it's now you
know that's the
uh prefrontal cortex and when and can
you now
invent and do things because
the doing of anything else um it becomes
increasingly
not worth anything because it could be
replaced by robotics and
other types of things and that creates
efficiencies and so on
but it also creates tremendous social
consequences
in terms of things like incomes and
wealth disparities and so on
that we haven't um begun to uh approach
like
how does one deal with that so there's
going to be
there are going to be revolutions uh
revolutionary changes ahead
in terms of all of those issues um
you know in other words okay how do you
deal with the wealth what does it mean
do you
have to be productive um what do you do
with those people is it cost effective
and then you think about even things
like how it's going to have
an impact on longevity i mean like if
you take a
average lifespan and so when you see
an upward curve and then you see the
reasons for that upward curve in
in many many ways wearables and
you know all sorts of things so the
world is going to change
in an incredibly fast pace and then
related to that that technological
change whoever wins the technology race
uh wins it all economically and
militarily so
yes that's what the next five years
looks like i think
all right look okay so you you i'm
intentionally perhaps have just set up
perfectly for the next session we have
to call it there because
we've got gary vaynerchuk coming up next
and he's going to be talking about nft's
non-fungible tokens which
is a really interesting way of thinking
about how do we you know start to deal
with all that create
creative uh innovation the the creative
product if you like and putting
some valuation on that so i mean this
was just a wonderful open
to this conference ray uh thank you so
much for doing this i think you've laid
out
some framing here for all of us to spend
the next three or four days
thinking about where the world goes and
what the role of of cryptocurrencies
uh blockchain and decentralized
technologies plays in all of this
thank you so much again for your time
really appreciate it uh i
wish we could have kept going we'll have
to have you back on uh some other time
and dig more
deeply into these things really
appreciate it thank you michael it was
it was a real treat thank you very much
thank you